that is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk and i'm dave
jewett the host of loadout the gamespot
show that delves into pop culture's most
iconic weapons and on today's episode
jonathan is going to be taking us
through one of the biggest and baddest
weapons in pop culture history the m134
minigun she brought a white lifting belt
yeah if i throw my back out now because
i'm trying to show off a minigun right
lift with your legs dave
if you like this kind of content please
make sure to subscribe as we have
episodes of loadout going up every
sunday and you can already check out our
previous episodes on everything from the
shotgun the m1 garand and the mythical
silver sword on top of that we'll still
be showing jonathan new gaming arsenals
every saturday so make sure to check
those out too first let's hear jonathan
explain the origins of the term minigun
[Music]
the name minigun is a bit incongruous
this is not a very mini gun it's a bit
like light machine gun you know light
machine guns are still heavy and a mini
gun is relatively miniature compared to
its granddaddy the vulcan 20 millimeter
aircraft and anti-aircraft cannon that's
why it's called the minigun so the m134
is its service designation in the us and
it's a 762 by 51 so 7.62 nato caliber
scaled down version of the vulcan cannon
that's in the f-16 f-18 f-22 in various
different subtly different forms your
aircraft cannon are basically giant
machine guns and then the mini gun is a
scaled down aircraft cannon firing a
rifle cartridge so in theory you could
stick one on a tripod and use it like an
l7 gpmg an fn mag
machine gun but that's not how we see
the minion minigun getting used it is
still a specialist
niche weapon
in the history of firearms development
the overarching theme is firepower more
bullets
more rapidly and so the very early
multi-shot guns you just have more
barrels that makes the whole gun heavier
for what it is so it's a trade-off the
same pros and cons high fire power but
massive bulk and weight apply equally to
the mini gun and that's why it has such
a limited niche basically vehicle
mounted it doesn't have an infantry roll
next we'll see jonathan break down the
gun itself but first we need to actually
get the damn thing on the table
where am i
[Music]
it does
but you'll be able to like
attempt to lift it
if you wish
you want to spin it around to make it
easier
so this
isn't anything but mini obviously
um we've talked a lot about the weight
and i mean i'm not
i didn't star in predator
but i think it has been asked that i try
and pick it up
which is just sitting in front of it is
quite intimidating
but
i mean i'll go that's not even all of it
you know it's missing that's the thing
right so this is this is without ammo
without
power
without the battery without any of it is
this is just
just the gun
jesus christ alive
no that's not no that's very heavy i
mean we knew it was going to be heavy
but you really need to
try and lift the damn things really
jesse ventura really yeah which
spoiler i am i'm not
but it's interesting
like you mentioned before about how much
of
the mini gun is is like hidden
movies and games so like there's
seemingly a power chord back here
power chord back there
and then we often see it with a sort of
big thick belt of ammunition where would
that
yeah so that comes in on the the right
hand side okay oh yeah there is a
load diagram there because as well as
this power
unit which isn't the power supply it's
just
the drive unit on the opposite side is
the d-linker feeding mechanism which is
this other cylinder here that's
necessary to actually get the ammunition
out of its link
in front of each bolt
and then throw the link out the side so
you've got like a feed mechanism on the
right hand side a drive mechanism on the
left hand side the actual gun is quite
mini when you compare it certainly if
you compare it to the vulcan just this
barrel cluster and a set of bolts inside
this
casing but obviously it weighs a hell of
a lot you've essentially got
six 762 machine guns
squished into one unit yeah and from
what you were saying about the rate of
fire
to to use this for any length of time
you need
a gargantuan amount of rounds in reserve
to put through the thing i guess i think
this one says aircraft
machine gun but what was this where did
this one come from um so this is um it
says on that gau which stands for gun um
aircraft unit 2 which is just its
designation equivalent to m16 but it's a
us air force
gun designation it's also known as an
m134 so this would be in the
door of a helicopter with a load of
other kit necessary to actually run it
and point it and some sort of sighting
system of course as well so this is as
light and as
portable as the so-called mini gun ever
gets and you
again like you said talking about jesse
ventura
you said he this was off camera earlier
but he pretends to [ __ ] it
i think that's what he's doing yeah i
mean it works wonderfully in the scene
as sort of macho nonsense which is
literally just
yeah i mean on camera i'm sure it looks
good in movies it's like big dude doing
thing with gun
it's implying something yeah
do you really need that when the thing
is this imposing
already
no but then that's that's what predator
is all about it's about you know matcha
it's a great technological over
confidence meets
techno primitive
alien who just wipes the floor with you
so
that shot among so many in that film
works absolutely perfectly in that you
know it speaks volumes i mean i've never
had to set up and use one of these
things so you know any any veterans um
that want to comment and advise
otherwise please do but as far as i know
that kind of
pump action shotgun-esque cocking for
emphasis thing is is not something you
would need to do maybe if there was a
stoppage and you were trying to clear
the stoppage you would need to manually
rotate the barrels like that but he's
just doing that to look cool
because if you need to look cooler when
you have
this thing yeah i mean no one's gonna
argue with you if you're you're man
packing a mini gun that's a great point
i don't envy the person that has to go
and put this away now
well now
we i don't have to directly put it back
in here so i suppose i can lift it all
the way somewhere
i would like to see you carrying the
whole way okay
she brought a white lifting belt
yeah if i throw my back out now because
i'm trying to show off a minigun right
lift with your legs dave
jesus christ that's that no i need to
put that down almost immediately
i'm gonna
slip a disc
which i imagine isn't very
helpful when you're fighting a giant
invisible alien wow definitely not yeah
yeah it's mini in relative terms only as
we said yeah
i feel like i need to lie down after
that thank you so much for watching this
episode of loadout if you enjoyed it
please do like the video and subscribe
and maybe even let me know in the
comments down below or on twitter at a
regular dave what you'd like to see an
episode on if you want more video game
firearms content you can watch the
previous episodes of this show or check
out our weekly series of expert reacts
where i show our friends at the royal
armouries a slew of guns to break down
until next time i've been your host dave
dewitt thanks again for watching and
i'll see you in the next one
[Music]
you